senator Elizabeth Warren announced
minutes ago she's forming a presidential
exploratory committee for the 2020
election the Massachusetts Democrat made
the announcement in a social media video
that was emailed to supporters at
O'Keefe is on Capitol Hill with this
major development in this next
presidential race good morning to you
good morning Michelle Elizabeth Warren
becomes the first u.s. senator to take
official steps to begin at 2020
presidential campaign she's been
planning for this for quite some time
but the announcement made today signals
she's serious about doing it in an email
sent to supporters this morning she says
she'll announce the rest of her plans
early in the new year the 69 year old
senator just won her second Senate term
in November while she represents
Massachusetts she was born and raised in
Oklahoma she was a law school professor
and is among the people credited with
coming up with the idea for the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau Warren has
faced criticism in recent months for her
attempts to prove her Native American
heritage through a blood test she did
that partly in response to President
Trump who often mocks the senator by
referring to her as Pocahontas Warren
has campaigned for other Democrats
across the country and has been keeping
in close touch with Democrats in early
primary States she would begin a
presidential campaign with dozens of
staffers already on her team and about
12 million dollars that she can transfer
from her Senate campaign account to a
presidential bid by the way because I
know someone at home must be wondering
there are six hundred seventy three days
to go Election Day 2020 fishel
announcement what does it really mean it
her now Michelle to essentially start
raising money to pay for the dozens of
staffers to pay for travel to Iowa or
New Hampshire South Carolina places we
expect her to go in the coming days
there's been talk about as many as two
dozen Democrats getting into this race
but we haven't seen that yet when are
they likely to get in on this
stay tuned probably in the coming weeks
folks like senator Cory Booker of New
Jersey Kirsten Gillibrand of New York
Kamala Harris of California Amy
Klobuchar Minnesota I checked with their
folks over the weekend
they're still spending these holidays
talking to family and making
preparations it sounds like quite a
parade ad thank you